Bruce Pearl he's the head coach at
Auburn last night they had a pretty good
run at Duke they're joining us in the
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach how are you this morning I'm
really glad to be on the Continental
Tire coaches quarter his Continental
Tire is a major sponsor of Auburn
basketball yes and and and they are
great people to work with so let's start
with last night what did you expect to
happen I thought we'd play better you
know Duke is in the mouth early Dan and
they don't play like freshmen and you
know I just thought that if we could
have knocked down some shots early and
maybe put a little scare into him then
we'd have a fighting chance instead of
the other way around when he came out
there they're confident they're talented
they're well coached they're as good as
advertised but it felt and you guys got
in early foul trouble there and that's
why I kept waiting for was Auburn gonna
be able to be Auburn basketball and then
we would see you know just how close
this game could be did you think that
maybe it was going to get out of hand
there early yeah we thought too much and
you know what makes Duke so good is is
that got some really tough one-on-one
covers I thought we did a really good
job on Zion Williamson last night you
know Kiki that was a great matchup for
us but we had a really hard time with
the other guards you keeping those guys
out of the lane and then once those guys
would make penetration it would draw a
defense they kick it out one of the ways
to beat them is to make perimeter shots
and they made you know enough perimeter
shots to win the game do you think
they'll go undefeated no no they're
beatable and I don't say that just you
know a lot of criticism they think first
of all they're not very deep their top
four freshmen plus the kid marques
Bolden who Dan has improved tremendously
a great story about you don't need to be
just a one-and-done to be successful
there's a
kid it's you know punched his clock for
three years and he's improved and didn't
transfer he wasn't getting playing time
because they were constantly bringing
all these great freshmen he got better
he's a real key to our team but they're
not real deep so if you know a team that
can get those guys in foul trouble
they're susceptible how would you
describe your pregame speech you know
you're it's just fire I mean you're so
excited you're pumped up your head is
exploding you know it's beet red and
then you go out there and you're down by
16 and I went up so much for that speech
you know sometimes you got to talk to
talk and then other times you have to
walk the walk and you know it's
interesting then you know what this is
going to be a third game now today in a
row and it it's psychologically and
physically especially the players really
really challenged it you know like
tonight the chanting sabers
you know there's AG against Duke or it's
gonna be you know which team got a
chance to play it's bench a little bit
more which team is going to be a little
fresher you know for us today we are
overtime win against Xavier and you know
a very hard-fought game you know to stay
within six against Duke we have Arizona
tonight
and it's you know this key this game
that would be playing against tonight
against Austin Arizona could be a
different outcome it was just one game
this week and so that's that's the kind
of gonna be interesting to see today all
these different matchups do coaches hang
out in Hawaii together now we have too
much tape to watch like like you know
right now it's 625 probably up for a
couple of hours kind of get caught up on
this
you know Arizona tape because these are
big games these games like matter in
March and so we don't hang out we don't
fish we don't go on the beach
hopefully our families do then and
they're having a great time but there
there are enough hours in a day for us
to you know get our teams prepared in
one day is it mandatory to wear a
Hawaiian shirt or a
No
No especially when you're sponsored by
Under Armour or Nike or adidas no they
want to see those they want to see those
locals so that we only not interested in
putting a Tommy Bahama on us in Maui got
a represent well why does it Nike or
Under Armour come up with a Hawaiian
shirt that's made specific for the Maui
Invitational yep that's me product
placement did you prepare more for RJ
Barrett cam radish or Zion last night
probably prepared more for Duke than any
one of those individuals you know when
you hear the term it's all about
matchups it is not a coin race it is
absolutely accurate in the study of just
scouting and one opponent versus another
one system versus another system and you
know some guys sort of just sort of have
your number certainly when it comes to
Duke it is about a personnel preparation
you've got to know science tendencies
you've got to know our James Tennessee's
they're both left-handed they don't like
to go downhill you know Hardy how do you
guard them and you want to make sure
that kids get enough film so they get it
gives them a fighting chance but I the
last thing I'll say you can't guard of
one I want you've got to be able to be
in gaps and and try to build a wall and
keep those guys on a perimeter if you
can what says a lot about you and the
program though that ranked eighth
already and you went toe-to-toe with
them and lived to tell about it so good
luck against Arizona it's always great
to talk to you coach thank you that's
that Bruce Pearl Albin head coach
Continental Tire coaches corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive or what you
drive Continental designs tires for what
you do for more information visit
Continental Tire dot-com Continental
Tire for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]